swapping sunshine for rain wasn't the
only bad news
thousands of holidaymakers back from
spain are being forced into a quarantine
they weren't expecting when they booked
their trip
i've just returned from portugal and
like me
they must fill in a form telling
government officials where they'll be
self-isolating for the next fortnight
we've been warned there will be spot
checks i haven't spoken to any official
about my quarantine
at gatwick airport i walked through the
automatic gate
caught a train and came home where i've
been ever since
i read the self-isolation rules on the
government's website
it told me i could exercise in the
garden but if i go any further
i could be fined a thousand pounds
but will everyone be happy or able to
abide by a lockdown
forced on them at short notice allowed
out
for only a few exceptions such as
essential food
and urgent medical help the government
seems to lurch from one decision to
another
there doesn't seem to be a consistent
strategy i don't think anybody knows
what they're doing
feel very let down we we felt
really safe in spain everywhere you went
everybody had face masks on
everyone social distancing in the
restaurants and bars
but it just seems a little bit a bit of
a downer now to be honest
now i've got a quarantine for 14 days
it's absolutely
ridiculous you government you need to
look into things you've got to get all
your mass gone and you get better get
this vaccination out
soon spot checks are carried out by
public health england
officials will call or text and alert
police
only if you don't respond after three
attempts
and police say they too will impose a
fine
only as a last resort since quarantine
began in early june
60 000 spot checks at people's homes
have been carried out by health
officials
only one fine has been imposed by police
in england and wales
three fines were handed out by the uk
border force
two of them at the french end of the
euro tunnel
spain is the first but it may not be the
last holiday destination
to have its air bridge removed and
re-imposed on travellers coming home no
one can rule out the risk of additional
quarantine requirements from other
european countries until we have a
vaccine
until that's rolled out you know very
widely
unfortunately these risks around
international travel are going to
continue
so far almost everyone has followed the
quarantine rules
police chiefs hope that compliance will
continue
martin brunt sky news